la hollandaise soraya ou ajouts 10 18
ans l'une des plus grandes championnes
de taekwondo de karaté au monde et à
saint quentin en yvelines
la sportive a passé quelques jours en
famille chez son grand-père à montigny
le bretonneux pour les vacances l'expert
en art martial en a profité pour
réaliser des vidéos dans la commune
yvelinoise afin de diffuser sa passion
sur les réseaux sociaux
astral est fausse
j'ai commencé le karaté à quatre ans
parce que mon père faisait du karaté il
m'a emmené voir un court je me suis dit
waouh c'est vraiment sympa alors j'ai
commencé mon sentiment par rapport au
karaté c'est que quand je fais ce sport
je fais ce que j'aime et j'adore
divertir les gens
depuis ses débuts la hollandaise volante
est vu par les observateurs comme un
prodige des espoirs confirmés par ses
performances sportives soraya remporté
des dizaines de trophées majeurs
j'ai gagné le tournoi de hollande
d'angleterre d'allemagne de belgique de
triche et le tournoi européen le mois
dernier je suis allé au pérou pour les
championnats du monde de taekwondo
j'ai fini troisième
donc je suis la troisième mondiale la
sportive a également participé à
plusieurs émissions de télévision comme
la version hollandaise d'un incroyable
talent en mai dernier
le show est regardé par plusieurs
millions de téléspectateurs j'ai fait du
karaté en freestyle pour cette émission
avec deux autres filles j'ai fait des
chorégraphies avec un sabre un bâton est
également un combat à 18 ans aurait ya
espère désormais participer aux
prochains jeux olympiques et tourné dans
des films ou des publicités